so this is Topsy turby and in order to
get a topsy turby effect that's
mechanically efficient I have to
establish a relationship between one end
of the lever and the other end of the
lever the two distal ends of the lever
you do that by establishing the center
and then you manipulate those distal
ends of the lever as far as possible in
the Topsy turbia effect so that's one
thing and then the other thing is you're
going to maintain connection with him so
that his weight will pull you over okay
and that's an adhesion all right so you
get you know you have to
depose
okay and here's one side of the lever up
here at the head and down here at this
foot
okay and then the other side of the
lever is here but if I try to do this
his Center is kind of gooy what I want
to do is bring him on to me that makes I
don't know why but people tense okay and
they tense just enough and I've taken
weight off of there but if he was like
super Slinky Slinky then you'll feel
like ah man that's heavy again okay so
it's more than there's just weight off
his knees okay you want you as you move
people will stiffen up and now now this
works okay and then I maintain
connection so I do my scissors sweep and
as he goes over just whever I'm touching
without locking up his
weight will pull me
over okay let's try it is very
tempting to uh go just do a like a a a
cap on this and then you push him over
with
that okay then but we want to work both
ends of the lever so I'm going to move
this it's going all the way over
there even if I smell that he's
going I still do it all the
way
okay don't get
lazy that's
got so even even as I'm holding him I'm
in that connection with him okay so as
he some people go one leg at a time they
start to stand you see I don't want to
contest this movement I'll I'll fall
into where I need to go and that's where
you're going to find the scissors sweep
okay and then you can
see if because you want to move the
distal ends as much as possible you have
to get to the distal end don't short
change it in here you were you stayed
attached to that point Let It Drop and
then you can see how much he's ready to
fall this way okay yes sir so doesn't
take as much as the administrative
version to get these relationships and
now you just do the same scissors sweep
stay
connected so you you maintain connection
he goes it's going to move you it moves
you you go he moves
you okay let him
move
he
goes moves me this part over here okay
don't pull it down you're moving it
forward all the adhering here is here
and here moves him forward you see that
it's not going down moveing
forward that's where you H
it cuz he's going to be he's going to be
trying to get up
okay once you touch the back of his neck
he's going to be trying to get it up so
let's get
there okay once you grab his neck he he
he's going to feel that precariousness
so as he goes up you don't want to hold
here you don't want to clench down on
that as he goes up you taking it that
way okay just
like uh when he gets up here you know I
don't try to shove it down I bring It
Forward same exact
thing I'm I'm light wherever I'm
touching
him light he tries to get up I'm
bringing it
Forward okay otherwise you got to be
stronger than him okay here we
go back to admin pendulum sweep okay you
got a couple choices you can either go
on the hip you can go on the
leg but you're going to try to turn 90°
to
him you can use your arm to come in okay
and what you want is this knee in the
armpit so keep your locks in there but
here's the part you do have to have that
arm in there okay so he doesn't post out
the bottom leg keeps straight cuz it's
going to attack the distal end of the
pendulum at the
bottom at the
end and you'll come
over keep this leg straight so you don't
make him land on you so
boom again bring him on you then start
to sweep you can keep this long this leg
so you get a good base and when you're
ready
then you take it
out stay connected so when the center of
gravity moves it moves you
too okay let's try
sir okay so any Topsy Turvy that you do
in a single plane so in the vertical
plane that as much mechanical advantage
as you have by working the distal ends
of the lever that still requires a great
deal of energy if you make this Topsy
turby thing travel across the mat in the
sagittal plane it takes less energy okay
so we were doing that in the other one
if you posts up here and when I brought
him this way you see he's traversing if
he stays here and I try to flip this
it's doable but that takes way more
energy than if I'm bringing it this way
then it's effortless okay so the more
ples you add especially the sagittal one
the less energy it takes to make the two
distal ends trade places all right so
same thing here when you come around
here you don't you want to make him
Traverse okay so this leg is I'm going
to game this leg this leg is actually
bringing him this way
when you add the arm and the hook and
everything it's much easier I'm going to
bring him this way you
see not this
way so bring him on you and he goes this
way much
easier
Okay add that sagittal plan try it again
in all your techniques right so find
doing
and he's going to try to resist uh it's
not that I drop on him and try to take
him down okay the energy that he resists
going up I take
forward okay every every technique's
like that so this is no
different okay so a guy is trying to get
up a lot of people should you should get
it you shouldn't stay down there's no
you have no business staying seated in a
closed guard okay but some people make
the mistake of getting up one leg at a
time or you you're making it hard for
him to get up one leg to get up both
legs at the time whatever the reason if
one leg comes
up you're going to look for the
precariousness that comes from
transitioning from his knee to his foot
okay that's what I'm looking for and
when I take that precariousness I'm not
trying to hold it down down as he goes
to stand up this motion is going forward
on the neck and then the knee pull is
going forward okay and as he starts to
go up I'm going to take him to the
side so that I get the side scissor get
my elbow Out start climbing on the back
he's not going to let me do that he's
going to try to get his head up and
start pushing back and now here
is your pendulum sweep
again don't contest anything directly he
goes one there it is Boom up here he
comes
pendulum okay try it
again